-♪♪ Think fast! ♪♪
-There you go.
Here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
One person asks the questions,
the other person has to answer
each question
as soon as it's asked.
And I mean immediately.
It doesn't matter if the answer
is right or wrong,
just has to be the very first
thing that pops in your head.
-And how do we win?
[ Laughter ]
Doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
-Doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter.
-Don't think like that.
Don't think like that.
-Doesn't matter.
-Aubrey,
because you're the guest,
I'll read your questions first.
-Okay.
-You ready for this?
-No.
-No, me neither.
Here we go.
This is "Think fast!"
-Okay. Should I shut my eyes?
Doesn't matter.
-You can shut your eyes
if you want to.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-No.
-Here we go.
-Okay.
-Who stole my bike helmet?
-My mom.
-Why does bread taste so good?
-It's got things in it.
-What's the theme of this year's
homecoming dance?
-Yellow forest -- forest.
[ Laughter ]
-How do doctors like to relax?
-Smoking it up, baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Describe Kevin.
-Ugh -- he sucks.
He always [bleep] [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Stop, stop.
-Sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is wrong with you?
-I don't know. I'm sorry.
-What's wrong with you?
-So many things.
-You can't do that.
-I know. I'm sorry.
-No, that wasn't the game
but yeah --
-Can we redo it?
-No!
-Damn it!
-You can't do that.
-How many times have you seen
"The Matchmaker?"
-I don't know. I'm --
-All right. All right.
-I don't deserve to be here.
-Yes, you -- Aubrey, here.
These are your questions here.
You ask me and I'll answer them
as randomly, fast as possible.
-Okay.
Set, go.
What are computers made out of?
-Cardboard.
-Where's the ballroom dance
this year?
-Upstairs.
-Why do you hate Debra?
-Because she's such a bitch!
-What's a combination of
a zebra and a hippo called?
-A zippopotamus.
[ Laughter ]
-Say something to impress me.
-Hi, there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Wow.
-Did that impress you?
-When you went, "Hi, there"?
-Hi, there.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I liked that.
-That's what I'm saying, yeah.
I just wanted to impress you.
All right, here we go.
It's the final round.
In this round we both pick --
-Not me. Don't pick me.
[ Laughter ]
-We have to. You're on the show.
Here's the way it's gonna work.
-We both pick up a card with
the same set of questions.
I'll ask one at a time
going back and forth.
I'll go first and then you.
-Okay.
-You'll see how --
-So the answer is the question?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You answer with an answer,
then you ask me the question.
-Copy that.
Roger.
Over and out.
-Copy that.
All right, ready for this?
-Nope.
-Okay.
When is Hanukkah?
-Tonya Harding.
Who is the greatest dancer
of all time?
-Courtney.
[ Laughter ]
What do I keep under my desk?
-Uh...snakes.
What's my middle name?
-Daschle.
What is your dentist doing
right now?
-Watching TV.
How do you say pancake
in German?
-Panakaka.
[ Laughter ]
Why did you get banned
from using Uber?
-I smacked him in the face.
Right in the face.
What would be a good name
for a cereal for dogs?
-Chubby-Wow-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-What is the deal with chairs?
-They're just so awesome.
I sit in them.
Sing me a song.
-♪♪ Oh, it is your birthday ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, it is your day ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, it is your birthday ♪♪
♪♪ Just one day of the year ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just wrote that song.
-Wow.
-That was "Think Fast!"
with Aubrey Plaza.